giving it to the cat he's home  secondhand finding Chris going to work  trying to navigate block by animal walk  by Alan sexing has it plenty of time  gotta kick it back out undaunted sexy  dancing speed to burn 118 118 the Nets  at shoe boy date on the clock  tied at 118 and there you sit over there  for that whole time and then forced to  shoot a huge shot in the triple overtime  Russell's feeling it oh yeah three  Angelo Nets have their largest lead of  the night for can they add to it Russell  D'Angelo Russell is lethal for sinners  went to the tacking on the spray Walker  has it over he's gonna hit that  set for fireworks at the finish  surely by one Russell he's unconscious  and then once again D'Angelo Russell  look at no-one's niram and nice shot by  kumari careless sneaky little screen  there before he's going to go to the  corner